okay this is a Diamond digger saga level
10 7 walkthrough tutorial this is a
tough level and it has some elements
that show up later in the game quite a
bit like the lava and the drop in the
totems as quickly as possible how to
plan man so we decided to make an extra
video with commentary to explain how to
best approach these types of levels in
most levels it's always best to start
from the top when you're trying to make
a path and here we have a pretty decent
setup you can see we can make this
yellow that's going to bring the water
out and then we can make this blue match
which will lead it to some of the lava
right away the reason you have to if
you're not familiar with all the reason
why you have to clear it out first is
because it continues to grow and it
blocks spaces to make matches so here
you know we can make two matches and
drop the totem to the bottom which
probably isn't that bad of an idea but
like when we make this first match this
level could grow right here and block
this block anyway so you know you could
do it that way but since we have a
yellow match and a blue match so it's
going to bring the water right to the
middle i'm going to i think that's the
better move and as you can see how that
did that if you made the blue one first
we probably still could have went back
and make the maybe yellow but you can
see how the lava blocks that offer we
you know we can't drop it any further
and the way we did it we we got all all
the lava Gong from the first couple
moves and now we just need to plan out
matches at the bottom to get out of this
room and this one was a lot like level
I'm going to go ahead and make you we
have two matches that will get us out
I'll explain that a little bit more but
this level is a lot like level 10 for in
that you really have to be careful not
to get your totem stock when you're
moving
down so just keep that in mind to plan
things out this is this room's the same
strategy except for this blog was a lot
harder to get to so we're going to work
from the top down again as much as we
can and you know you'll get stuck
sometimes like we did right there but
that's why this love is hard so not much
you can do about it but keep moving on
and we got all brittle over lava so now
we just want to carefully plan how to
drop these two totems um excuse me have
a cold so I'm a little stuffed up I'm
going to make this match first let's see
yeah we can make this one and then this
one I'm lotus-eyed one doc left and
since there's only two colors if there's
some space usually you'll get the
matches you need you can certainly get
stuck in the process but for the most
part you can move from the top to the
bottom alright so our color burst is
charged but I'm not going to use it
unless I need it which I don't add too
much as I can get out of here so I'm
going to go ahead and do it that way and
the reason is can we all have that
meeting that moves left and we
absolutely need to try to keep this
intact for this segment here because as
you can see it's a little more
complicated we have to get the law of a
Down and we have to work with more
colors we have three colors here instead
of two so dropping these tones can take
a little bit more so this is a good
match here this is going to bring water
to the middle
and now we just need to get it down one
more step you could use the booster
right now let's see what we can do if we
do it if we match it on green will clear
out all this space and drop a tums a
little bit and then we should be able to
clear the law in one match however we
can just match this yellow here or this
blue here and still doing two men two
matches and we'll save the booster so
we're going to do about all right so now
our love is gone we have to worry about
that anymore so now we just have to plan
things out to bring the totems down as
quickly as possible and I am going to go
ahead and use the booster right now
clear out some of these greens because
then we'll have like really big yellow
and the launches to choose from
let's see we can
you can safely make this match because
we know there's going to be a balloon
marriage left behind and we may have
just got ourselves stuck over here I
mean we can get it in two moves we're
not gonna have that many matches left so
that might have done the same
unfortunately no no we're going to blue
like we wanted to now I can just make
these two last two matches and be down
to level so you can see that planning is
really important and even simple matches
you want to take your time to think
because we're finishing this on the very
last move and I don't happen quite a bit
so you want to save every move and
playing your matches so things don't get
stuck if you have any questions about
this definitely check our full guide on
level 1 07 first it talks about how to
approach each one of the Rings and I'll
leave a comment if you need to we'll
definitely try to get back to you as
fast as we can please like the video if
you found it helpful those help us out a
lot and visit our site and leave
comments there if you have questions or
if you want to see a video like this
with commentary for a different level
you're having trouble with time
permitting we'll go ahead and make one
of those for you alright thanks